welcome to this webinar on
bioinformatics for precision oncology
precision medicine is changing the way
we understand
diagnose and treat cancer the
transformation
is driven by high throughput molecular
data from
patients animal models and large-scale
cell line experiments
in this program we will explore how high
throughput data can be analyzed
to study the genomic background of
cancer
comics data that describes the basic
biology associated with
cancer onset development and outcomes
and see how large-scale data sets
collected from
clinical trials provide an opportunity
to better understand
this condition and improve the precision
of clinical oncology
the goal of omits logic programs
is to provide training in bioinformatics
enabling independent research
guided by mentors and peer example
developing a growing community with
shared passion for data-driven research
and appreciation
of citizen science enabling students
researchers
and faculty of all backgrounds to
develop novel and independent research
using latest technology in life and data
sciences
over the course of the past several
years our team has been collaborating
with a number of academic institutions
around the world that have participated
in content evaluation curriculum review
and project design
as a result the omics logic programs
have been thoroughly
evaluated and are known to lead to
excellent outcomes
my name is beepsha biswas and i'm the
omixlogic community manager responsible
for
daily interaction with thousands of
users who are
part of our bi-informatics community
managed by pine biotech
the omics logic programs like precision
oncology
and the educational resources we will
discuss today
and throughout this program is a result
of hard work by an
amazing team led by company co-founders
dr
alfred tauber and dr jonet brodsky
dr tober comes from a medical background
and has
extensive expertise in oncology
immunology and biochemistry of
inflammation and has been recognized
internationally for his generous support
of many research projects and
initiatives that support
training and applications in medicine
dr brodsky is the director of the tauber
bioinformatics research center
at the university of haifa and is an
expert in bioinformatics and
biostatistics he has numerous
publications
in mathematics and bioinformatics and
over the course of his career has
developed
multiple novel algorithmic approaches to
biomedical data analysis
under his leadership the chober research
center
started collaborations with research
teams
such universities like the university of
california san francisco
institute pastor julian university and
many
others where research labs are working
on
cutting-edge research projects studying
various viral and bacterial infections
and designing novel
drugs and vaccines the rest of the team
you see here
includes experts in bioinformatics
computer science
and training and some of our team would
be presenting today
so let me introduce you to the team
behind this webinar and the upcoming
program
we have dr harpreet kaur who is a
certified omics logic trainer and an
expert by information
and will guide the hands-on sessions and
assist participants with projects
and analysis during the program her area
of specialization is in genomics and
machine learning
dr mohit mazumdar is the omixlogic
project mentor and an
expert in big data computational
analysis
dr malzundar has a phd in computational
biology and over 10 years of experience
working with
industry and academia ilia brodsky
is the co-founder and ceo of pine
biotech
in his current role he has extensive
experience working together with
industry and academic partners that are
applying
multi-omics integration and
bioinformatics to a variety of
biotechnology
and clinical applications we also have
clinton kunha who is
joining us as one of the omics logic
bioinformatics trainer for this program
he has a master in bioinformatics from
the university of guelph
and masters in cellular and molecular
medicine from the university of otawa
i would now like to invite elia brodsky
our ceo to discuss
more about the upcoming session and the
importance of precision medicine in
cancer research and therapeutics
over to you elia thank you very much
and glad to be here with all of you and
the rest of the team
and what i hope that you will learn in
this webinar is how bioinformatics could
be applied to precision oncology
some project examples that you can learn
from as well as
a link between biological understanding
and clinical applications and the future
of precision oncology
so let's start by talking a little bit
about cancer biology
the fundamental traits of cancer cells
involves their ability to sustain
chronic proliferation
evade growth suppression activate
invasion and metastasis enable
replicative
immortality induce angiogenesis
and resist cell death and this has to do
with the property of the tumor itself
as well as how this these cells interact
with
its micro environment the tissue around
it directly around the tumor
as well as the rest of the body so you
can think of these
specific features as a
hallmark feature of cancer so again you
can kind of think of
the original six like sustaining
proliferative signaling
evading growth suppression activation of
invasion
and metastasis enabling replicative
immortality
inducing angiogenesis and energetics
and resisting cell death and in recent
uh
several years in the past several years
some
additional ones were added to this list
so these
include deregulating cellular energetics
avoiding immune destruction tumor
promoting inflammation
genome instability and mutation so these
are some of these
fundamental hallmarks of cancer
and one of the ways that these hallmarks
could be studied
is through the understanding of genomic
components or the genomics
of these cancer cells so when we think
about the genomics of cancer cells we're
really talking about
next generation sequencing and how it
allows us to look
deep inside the cell inside the nucleus
and discover the changes
at the dna level then see the result of
those mutations at the rna level
as well as study the controlling
mechanisms at the level of
epigenetics or how the dna is available
for translation and transcription
and how it is changing with different
methylation
tags in dna methylation so importantly
when we speak about the basic
characteristics of cancer
those could be studied at different
levels at some mechanistic
basic level we can analyze
patient-derived cell lines that
represent
some of the most prominent
characteristics and study how they
develop over time in a variety of
different cancers
tissues and stages of disease
progression
however cell line cultures do not
represent the system's biology which is
such a major component of cancer as well
as the other
factors that play along like the tumor
micro environment
what has been developed over the past
several years is a way to look at the
system's biology by
grafting in the tumors to animal models
as a result we can see some of the
interaction that happens
between the tumor itself and the micro
environment
however the animals do not fully
represent
the systems biology of the patient
population
primarily because immunocompromised mice
are used so that the tumors could be
engrafted
and the animal biology is not exactly
replicative
of a patient and that's why in recent
trials large multi-omic
data sets have been compiled to allow us
to study
real patient populations at the
multi-omics level
including clinical data that offers
unique insight into comorbidities
as well as the effects of cancer therapy
and so when we talk about this challenge
as a result of collection
collecting data from these multiple
sources
many clinicians are faced with this
challenge of
knowing how to process analyze
and integrate such data from different
repositories
accounting for the different properties
of big data
such as volume variety value
veracity and velocity and so knowing
how to manipulate data and manage it
effectively
is critical for anyone interested in
learning
about this molecular component or the
genomic component
of precision oncology this key
technology called
next generation sequencing or second
generation sequencing
essentially represents a high throughput
an automated process that develops
a data set over a series of
experiments and one of the key steps in
analyzing this data is processing this
data so what we'll do in this
program is focus on how to effectively
utilize different methods of analysis
that help us understand the basic
relationship between phenotypes that we
observe
and the genomic data that are captured
in this next generation sequencing so
one of the major things that we will
look at are differentially expressed
genes
how to utilize statistical analysis like
regression
and how to look at exploratory data
analysis
with biological interpretation how to
link
the identified genes with particular
pathways that are so important to
understand
as we are looking at the deregulation of
these traditional
pathways in cancer cells now
importantly we will look at a number of
important data sets
collections of data that represent the
challenges
and the opportunities in developing
novel
cancer treatments and diagnostics using
such repositories like the cancer genome
atlas or tcga so here we have
now over 30 tumor types that have been
studied
by collecting data from genomics
transcriptomics epigenomics and
proteomics
that really allow us to study this
process of tumor development growth and
metastasis
from the systems biology perspective and
what we'll do is we'll take
case studies examples of data
that come from high impact projects that
have been
published in high impact journals and
peer reviewed studies
that will allow us to see how we can
utilize advanced statistical methods and
machine learning
techniques to transform these
collections of data
into automated and insightful
technologies to study
tumor variation and even analyze
therapeutic response based on molecular
profiles
we'll also talk about how this changes
the clinical understanding of cancer
where instead of relying on the biology
or the clinical knowledge and intuition
about a particular disease
we can turn to machine learning and
artificial intelligence
to know how the particular sample that
we're looking at
correlates with some of the known
samples
and classes in different cancer studies
we'll take a look at the metadata and
the clinical factors that represent
different types of risks as well as
different impacts
on disease outcomes so i hope that
this is a brief introduction in today's
webinar will really give you an insight
into how important next generation
sequencing
big data analysis processing and machine
learning
can play in the cancer oncology research
as well as translational studies that
impact the clinical use
of data in precision oncology so
now i want to introduce you to our uh
trainers in this omixlogic program dr
harpreet kaur
please go ahead thank you
so hello everyone my name is harpreet
kaur
and i have a phd in bio informatics
let me give you some claims how
bioinformatics
can be helpful in identifying biomarker
or signatures for a specific malignancy
by taking few examples from my doctoral
research
work so my phd research was on biomarker
discovery
for diagnosis and prognosis of liver
cancer
using bioinformatics
so what inspired me to study liver
cancer
is the high mortality rate of this
malignancy
and a lack of precise biomarker that can
help
diagnose liver cancer at an early stage
it is considered as sixth major cancer
in terms of incidence
and fourth in terms of mortality across
the globe
so liver cancer is often at times
misdiagnosed or detected too early
for an effective treatment another
factor that contributes to its poor
outcome
of the liver cancer patient is frequent
reoccurrence
so with these concern by keeping these
concerns in mind
we have framed
some objectives to collaborate with
collaborate to address these issues
using bioinformatics so for the first
part of
this research project we used a large
scale transcriptomics data
to identify diagnostic biomarker panel
for hepatocellular carcinoma which is
primary liver malignancy so in this
study
we have employed 30 data sets from
a public repository that is geo and tcga
that containing nearly four thousand
sample
to lucid a transcriptomics biomarker
panel
for the diagnosis and the prognosis of
the liver cancer
using various statistical and
bioinformatics techniques
for the next part of this project we use
transcriptomics
and methylation data of hepatocellular
carcinoma patients
from the tcga to identify biomarker
panel
for the stage classification of this
malignancy
so here we employed tcga data of 350
samples
and elucidated 51 features that
include 30 rna transcripts and 21
cpg methylation size using number of
data mining
techniques among them particularly the
name base model
is top performer that classify early and
the late stage sample
with an accuracy nearly 79 percent
and for the next part of this project we
use
transcriptomics data to scrutinize
diagnostic biomarker panel
for palengio carcinoma which is another
major liver malignancy
so in this study we have taken nine data
sets
from public repository geo which contain
350 chlangiocarcinoma 133
adjacent non-tumorous and 90 hcc sample
to secretinize clenzio carcinoma
specific
signature using multiple machine
learning techniques
like extra tree random forest logistic
regression
etc so in the conclusion
here we have identified three gene based
marker that can discriminate as cc
from the normal samples then we have
identified another three gene based
signature
that can identify cleanser carcinoma
from scc and the normal samples
at last we have identified 51 features
that include 30 rna transcript and 21
methylation cpg site
to discriminate early and the least is
samples of scc
so in my current role i'm omik's logic
bioinformatics trainer with the pine
biotech
i am assisting participants to learn
about
data analysis machine learning and
visualization
in application to the last data set used
in biomedical research
besides i am involved in designing
different research projects
using publicly available data sets
and using our various tools that are
integrated
on our web server so to provide
hands-on training and to make
participants
familiar with the approach to design and
complete a research project
we are continuously designing different
research projects using publicly
available data
based on the studies published in high
impact journal
thus we have a collection of research
projects
where you can learn new how
bioinformatics can be applied in the
field of oncology
using publicly available data set to
drive
biological and clinical important
biomarker for a specific cancer
conditions
so one of these project is similar to my
phd research work so in continuation of
the liver cancer
here i have designed a project with our
pine biotic team members
for identifying molecular signatures
that are
associated with the clinical factors of
the liver cancer patients
based on integration of multi-omics data
so here we have explored different omics
data
types like rna mi rna and demographic
data
employing multi omics data integration
approach for liver cancer patient to
find out the molecular signature that
are associated with clinical phenotypes
of the patients
as one of the major challenge with
malignant conditions
is that singulomics data is not
sufficient
to design highly efficient biomarker
thus multi ohmics data types can fill
that akuna
and fill will facilitate to design
official signature
but then major challenge is the
integration of
those multi-omics data types either you
need to develop
an individual pipeline for each data
type
then you will find an approach or a
method to
integrate them together so for this you
required
high computational or bioinformatics
skill
so to remove these obstacles various
multi omics data integration tools like
snf i cluster plus
o2 pls are integrated on t by one for
server
where users just need to provide input
data sets
and can easily perform various types of
multi-omics analysis
by just click on options so in this
project
we have also implemented these tools to
done various kind of analysis
finally we are trying to fi trying to
understand how multiomics data
integration
analysis can provide us holistic picture
of this lethal malignancy
and also how they are associated with
diverse clinical phenotypes
like tumors days risk factors race is
gender of the patients
so participants can explore these
projects during this upcoming program
thereof there are number of research
fellows who have completed their
research projects
in the field of oncology with pine by
biotech
research fellowship program so ms
urja parikh who is post graduate student
from india
completed her research project
entitled identification of biomarker to
differentiate between
neural stem cell and glioblastoma stem
cell
employing publicly available data
using various bioinformatics tools
that are available on tbinfo server
our another research fellow
simi dolana who who is a undergraduate
student from turkey
recently completed her research project
that
is for long non-coding rna as
therapeutic target
in chronic lymphocytic leukemia using
publicly available data
for this malignancy and employing
various bioinformatics techniques
that are integrated on a server
then we have another research fellow
kalamari maru who is a phd student
from mexico he has completed his
research project
for classification of triple negative
breast cancer cell line
by gene expression analysis of
transmembrane protein
using machine learning algorithm so he
has done
study on a breast cancer cell line
employing
different data mining techniques that
are available on t
bind for server so i'm looking forward
for being your mentor in the upcoming
comics logic
program now i would like to pass this
session to our another mentor
clinton so over to you clinton
thank you dr cower
okay
picking up from where you left off i
would also like to highlight
the importance of precision medicine in
oncology
my name is clinton kuna i am a double
masters graduate from the university of
guelph
and the university of ottawa
i did a masters in bioinformatics and
molecular medicine
i completed my bachelor's degree at
carnegie mellon and i'm familiar with
data and
analytics in the context of biological
data
i know how to program in r python and
unix and i've won
awards related to my first masters and
bachelor's degree
mainly due to my presentation skills
in order to create practical
applications in precision medicine
within the context of oncology one needs
to understand the basic biology
behind certain mechanisms and utilize
bioinformatics
to find or create new relationships that
can be translated to the clinic
this could include understanding tumor
gene expression patterns
biomarker structure and several other
contexts
it is important to visualize
cancers to determine their mode of
spread
there are current technologies that use
less than
probes in order to identify highly
expressed cancers
related to genes within the body by
capturing these images
this acts as a first step in obtaining
gene expression values for that
particular cancer
one can then use bioinformatics
approaches to determine the significance
of different genes for personalized
treatment
i used a gene library with human surface
proteins
in order to find better pro proteins
that can be used
as future biomarkers within my
bachelor's thesis project
as you can it indicates
where there are highly expressed these
cells
that were mixed with dye under the flow
cytometer
we isolated 20 high or moderate
individual biomarkers
through sorting they were then sequenced
and aligned to a reference genome using
bioinformatics software
in order to determine where single
nucleotide
polymorphisms or snips account for their
high
fluorescence when compared to low
fluorescent proteins
so cancer is extremely heterogeneous
and there is so much data out there
there are several proteins that play
different roles within certain contexts
it's quite a challenge to organize all
this data
let's take the example above with a
particular protein
known as c20 like kinase or slk
it plays a role in important cellular
processes
such as proliferation migration and
apoptosis
it affects development and is shown to
play a role in tumor genesis
within a new induced mammary tumor model
within mice
an slk knockout increased the time it
took for a tumor to form
and also increase the expression of
sox10 an important biomarker in cancer
slk regulates the akt proliferation
pathway through feedback in inhibition
but its absence causes akt to be hyper
activated
slk might be might play a role in other
contexts as well
which only enlarges the amount of
biological data that needs to be
processed
in mouse embryonic fibroblasts slk
knockout reduces focal adhesion
turnover it seems that slk has different
roles with a particular context
research on slk is ongoing this is
similar to cancer
every cancer is different and it's a
challenge to determine where those
differences exist
we need more advanced methods to
determine why a knockout reduces a
process in one context
but increases it in another my master's
thesis project propelled me into a route
where i can use more sophisticated
methods of analysis
such as machine learning algorithms to
solve these complex discrepancies
within cancer
so therefore i decided to pursue a
master
in bioinformatics and learn those
complex skills
pure biology is good but having the data
and
analysis skills to create meaningful
relationships
definitely solves major problems that
can be translated into applications
within medicine
bioinformatics has exposed me to other
fields due to its
bio bioinformatics interdisciplinary
nature
such as statistics engineering and
mathematics
bioinformatics can help translate basic
research into meaningful relationships
there's a current need to identify what
brain cells particularly do
using machine learning algorithms we can
classify cells into new categories that
can help us pinpoint
which cells cause disease we don't
particularly know
the exact cause or mechanism of
alzheimer's disease
however using multi-omics approach of
collecting gene expression values of
patients
in a longitudinal study which eventually
leads to patients
developing alzheimer's one can
potentially
potentially use machine learning
algorithms
to find a particular trend in the
project
above the ultimate goal was to create a
database of brain cells
with their respective function in all
conditions
disease and normal to start
one needs to test existing algorithms on
controlled data
to determine appropriate classification
therefore
i completed a master's project by
analyzing single cell rna-seq data
from a region within the normal mouse
spring to test the accuracy of these
algorithms
and therefore use these algorithms
within a new context
i compared four different dimensionality
reduction techniques
two being experimental and two control
in order to predict
g accurate gene ontology membership gene
ontology membership is a way scientists
classify genes in
into biological processes in a variety
of species
it can be thought of as a database with
the blueprints of life
the first step of this project was to
reduce the gene and sample matrix into
less dimensions
as shown in the figure here
the second step was to train different
types of classifiers
such as logistic regression and support
vector machine
the final step was to use the data to
predict gene ontology groups
as you can see t-distributed stochastic
neighbor embedding or t-sne
accurately predicted gene ontology
groups that are related to the brain
since that is where the data set was
derived from if you look at the title
column
you'll see words such as synapse neuron
projection
and neuron development these techniques
can also be used to determine new cell
types
in a cancer tumor and therefore
understand what types of cells cause a
particular disease
determining new cell types and patterns
helps individuals administer
personalized therapeutics there is a
need to find new patterns in biological
data
particularly cancer data traditional
approaches are generic
and have their disadvantages such as
secondary cancers and unwanted stress to
the patient
using bioinformatics to develop a
personalized approach
you can help that person's mother
survive a breast cancer
that could have increased due to genetic
use of chemotherapy
the the precision oncology program will
give you the analytical
statistical and conceptual skills to
find
patterns in curated data sense these
techniques
are standard bioinformatics pipelines
used by bioinformaticians
throughout the world now i will pass it
to biepsha
to talk more about the program
thank you so much clinton
i would now like to invite our student
researchers
to present their work on cancer research
we have
semi dholana who has been working with
our team
on her novel research project as part of
the research fellowship program
and would present on therapeutic targets
in chronic lymphocytic leukemia and then
we will hear from sonalika ray
who is joining us as our research intern
and will present her review on liver
cancer research
over to you semi
hello everyone i hope you can hear me
well
yes we can hear you clearly thank you
okay hello everyone once again i'm
smiling
studying molecular biology and genetics
at bachelor university in turkey
i'm working as an undergraduate research
assistant in a cancer biology laboratory
and until now i studied non-small cell
lung carcinoma and pancreatic cancer
in the vet lab focusing on cell cycle
emt mechanism and metastasis
and also chronic neophysitic leukemia
and dried up with the experience with
pine biotech
actually my knowledge of bioinformatics
and computational biology was very
limited
and that's why i wanted to improve
myself in this field because
as you know as a scientist we need to be
able to see the big picture
as much as the small details so in order
to do this we should have the knowledge
of the big data science and need to
learn how to process
and analyze high throughput data so
while
i was looking for an opportunity to gain
experience and knowledge
i came across the pinewood tech
fellowship program and enrolled as an
intern for three months during this
period
i took several online courses about omix
technologies
and machine learning which was a great
environment to learn
and practice with hands-on assignments
moreover there were several quizzes for
each course
in order to evaluate ourselves and
repeat the information
so i can say that courses were very
helpful for me because it was starting
with the basic information
and continuing by increasing the
complexity
also i had the opportunity to
participate in webinars like this one
and these were very beneficial because
it was increasing my curiosity for the
upcoming details
so one of the best sides of this program
was to have
weekly meetings with our mentors and
other participants
each week we were sharing our progress
asking our questions and discussing them
together
it was a really positive environment to
learn and discuss the topics
additionally when i needed anything
anytime i could be able to contact and
go
and get a guidance from my advisors
immediately without waiting
uh for the weekly meetings furthermore
there were two huge opportunities that i
can benefit from
and the first one is the tea bioinfo
server which is the platform that we are
using for processing and analyzing the
data
and it's very user friendly that even
with a little knowledge you can learn
and practice with it
step by step and the second one is the
codonx logic platform
actually coding was very hard and
complex for me
but this platform explains and shows the
coding with very basic steps so
even though i had some difficulties it
it made coding more enjoyable for me
so my favorite part of this program
was to have an individual project which
was the place to show
our knowledge and the practices so like
the theory needed to become practical
it was a great opportunity to come up
with a hypothesis
and developed answers over time so
nearly
within two months i completed a project
titled identification
of link rnas as therapeutic targets in
chronic lymphocytic leukemia
so my main goal was to identify possible
therapeutic targets
in order to be able to trigger the
spontaneous regression mechanism
which is the disappearance of the tumor
over time
with or without any treatment in
different cancer types
for this i use an rna-seq dataset from a
bioproject
that can be found in cbi basically with
the help of the tibet infoserver
i conducted transcriptomics analysis by
comparing spontaneous regression and the
progressive state of chronic lymphocytic
leukemia
i determined differentially expressed
genes among two groups
by differential gene expression analysis
and identified significant genes
through statistical analysis
consequently significant protein coding
genes were correlated with
rna related pathways therefore i
investigated the
non-coding genes and found highly
expressed 33
link rnas with further analysis i
identified three significantly rnas that
can be
important in regression mechanism and
can be used as
therapeutic targets but of course if
these findings are
confirmed by additional studies we can
say that
these found link rnas can be used as
therapeutic targets
so my research revealed new perspectives
regarding spontaneous regression and its
association with
link rnas in final words
this research fellowship program enabled
me to master the field of bioinformatics
more than i thought and
in my new project i definitely plan to
use high throughput data
and perform more comprehensive studies
and once again thank you to the
pine biotech team for this wonderful
environment
thank you thank you so much
semi now i would like to ask a sonalika
to go ahead with a presentation so
nalika over to you
yeah we can hear you but barely enough
um good evening everybody i am
pursuing masters in bioinformatics from
punjab university india
today i am here to discuss the review on
hepatocellular carcinoma which is
abbreviated as hcc
i will be shedding light on the risk
factors involve
gene mutations treatment and scope of
research in this field
starting with what is fcc it is the most
common form of liver cancer
it is a second leading cause of cancer
death in the world and there have been
between
6 lakh to 1 million new hcc cases in the
world annually
so this is clearly still an important
area for basic science
research and clinical science and drug
development
the highest incidence and mortality of
hcc
are observed in east asia africa europe
and in the usa
now i would like to discuss few risk
factors which are associated with hcc
so patients with cert horses chronic
alcohol
consumption are at a higher risk for scc
infection by hepatitis b virus and c
virus
so hepatitis b virus related hcc
is more prevalent than a hcv related hcc
non-alcoholic fatty liver disease that
is nafld
and nash that is not alcoholics keto
hepatitis are another risk factors
associated with metabolic syndrome or
diabetes mellitus
now few polymorphisms in the genes given
that is pnp la3 tm
6sf2 at hsd hsd17b13
have been identified to be associated
with the severity of nash and fcc
incidents another risk factors are
cirrhosis from
primary binary cholangitis
hemochromatosis
alpha-1 anti-trypsin deficiency
also aristologic acid and tobacco
are found to be potential pathogenetic
cofactors in hcc
so high throughput next generation
sequencing has
enabled the identification of cancer
driver genes
with oncogenic functions or tumor
suppressive functions
that are currently altered in hcc
so the few cancer driver genes related
to scc
are telomerase activation via turf
promoter mutations
viral insertions chromosome
translocation or gene amplification
these are the most frequent driver gene
mutations
observed in 80 percent of hcc cases
activation of wnt beta catenan signaling
pathway
was demonstrated in one of the studies
and was supposed to have 30 to 50
percent cases related to hcc
other mutations of the genetic
alterations were found in these genes
given
all of which alter cell cycle control
recurrent local chromosome
amplifications in the genes
ccnd1 fgf19 wedge fa
nyc are met led to over expression
result in the activation of various
oncogenic signaling pathways
including receptor tyrosine kinases
although cancer driver genes uh
mutations accumulate randomly
specific genes are related to precise
molecular hcc subclasses
which are defined by transcriptomic
profiles and histological
phenotypes thus the transcriptomic
analysis the study
becomes more prevalent here
now i would like to discuss few of the
hcc related mutation signatures
and then the role of adaptive immune
system in biomarkers
so hepatocytes progressively accumulate
numerous epigenetic changes and genetic
mutations which are associated with
specific mutation signatures as
observed signatures 22 24 4 and 16.
so these observations underline the role
of the liver
in detoxifying numerous metabolites
which can damage the hepatocyte genome
by inducing passenger or driver
mutations
leading to carcinogenesis
does the study of these signatures are
of utmost importance
then the role of adaptive immune system
in fcc is such
that the functional cd8 plus t cells
they express
empty tumor effector molecules and
trig cells they are considered a major
culprit
in mediating t cell dysfunction in hcc
the biomarkers of response to systemic
therapies
are still under investigation but
the first biomarker which was predictive
of response
was studied as alpha phetoprotein
other biomarkers are still under
investigation
these are afpl three osteopontine and
glypicam3
now talking about the treatments for hcc
so hepatic resection liver
transplantation from refined patients
local ablation
they have been the mainstay curative
treatments in fcc cases and
taste and tear to remain the same
they show efficacy in phase 2
investigations but has not been employed
into practice
you see we have so many drugs which are
developed for hcc
the list goes on as shown but there was
just one drug so despite much money and
research only
one drug sold after nib was approved in
the u.s or globally for use and patience
with
hcc this companies they need to work
more closely with the fda to come up
with ways to profile tumors
and find the right medication to treat
the right patient
this finding receptors in signaling
pathways that are dominant
and then using the right medication or
combination therapy with
tumor biopsy could be beneficial
so you see there's such a vast scope of
research in hcc
employing cat techniques we could either
design or look for possible ligands
for mutational drivers we need to
identify biomarkers
as a better biomarker panel is needed as
tumor tends to be heterogeneous in
nature
it tends to be heterogeneous and then
the biomarker panel also needs to be
multifaceted
so that clinicians can assess a patient
who may be producing one type of
biomarker
but not the another we could also
collate all the information
from gene signatures gene mutations
related risk factors biopsy images
possible treatment and then build a
predictive model which could be
used by the clinicians for better
diagnosis
and treatment so this would be our basis
for further research in
scc further proceedings are yet to be
employed by our team as in looking for
the data sets and creating the workflow
this project would be under dr harpreet
course mentorship
and we are open for interns or research
fellows to join the project
we would be glad to collaborate thank
you
now i i would like to pass it on to
biepsha
to discuss other project platforms
thank you so much sonalika and thank you
semai
for sharing this wonderful presentation
and your experiences with us
now i would introduce everybody to the
program resources
for different parts of the session we
will leverage
omits logic resources where you can use
to learn more about precision oncology
these will include
a synchronous coursework with
theoretical
material quizzes and practical
assignments
our cloud-based analytical server where
you can
analyze large genomic data and visualize
results
the omics logic code playground where
you can practice
coding in rn python as well as a
repository of project examples
so here is the first resource
which is the edut bio info platform
throughout the program we will leverage
our top rated
online tutorials using this eduti
bioinfo portal
which has a smart tracking of activity
and curated data sets designed for a
great
learning experience throughout the
course you will be given directions
to access the tbio info platform or the
server.tbioinfo platform
for bi-informatics processing and
analysis
of rna-seq data the platform
includes demo pipelines as well as data
management and analysis
cloud infrastructure to run
bioinformatics pipelines
different stages of analysis are
performed in different sections
of this multi-omics platform
and behind many of the methods are
strips written in popular coding
languages such as rn python
and as you heard semi also say
these would be explained to you in
tutorials using the code omics logic
platform
where we will learn about r and python
for
biological data sets
at the end of this two month program
participants will receive
a certificate which can either be a
certificate of completion
or a certificate of excellence depending
on your progress
in the program
like if you see in our previous programs
there are participants who have
completed these trainings successfully
like you see olga udatseva here who is a
postdoctoral researcher
at roswell park cancer center and used
her experience to learn about data
analysis techniques
which she is now applying to her own
pre-clinical research i would now
like to open this session for any
questions that you may have regarding
the
program or if you have any other
questions related to the resources
so please put those questions down in
the chat box
and i do have a few questions for you so
right now i would be launching a poll
that you can see on your screen i hope
that the poll is visible to everybody
so the poll has a few questions uh which
we hope that you can answer
and this will help us to learn more
about you
so the first question is which country
are you from i know a lot of you have
already
put in your answers before so thank you
for answering
but there are others who are coming from
countries which are not listed here so
please put down your
answers in the chat box the second
question is what is your
level of education so we have put in
bachelor's degree master's degree phd
and post-doc
while you can also put in any other
degrees that you may have
thank you mormon for sharing in the chat
box
and we are also asking you who are you
are your student a faculty researcher
clinician or
you have any other posts that you
recognize with so you can also vote us
there
and we are also asking you to rate your
experience in today's session
so i would keep the poll on for a few
more minutes
and
and also i have another question for all
of you so what was the most useful part
of the presentation so you can write
that down
in the chat box so this is like a
question that i am asking you we hope
that this presentation
was useful for all of you
yes so maureen uh as you saw in today's
presentation we have had
our mentor team who are here dr harpreet
kaur
ilya brodsky even clinton
as well as dr mohit mazumdar so they
are going to be the mentors who are
going to
guide you throughout this process so if
you are new to this field
we will be helping you out with your
step-by-step process the entire learning
process
yes so rains uh you are raising
[Music]
uh your hand if you have any question
please let us know
so we have a question from ishaan here
are the lessons
more data focused yes the lessons are
more data focused
so i i should give you all an
overview of the courses that are there
so let me stop
sharing the presentation right here and
i'll also end the poll right now
so okay going back
so let us take a look at the courses
that are there
so each of these courses that you see
here
are based on the different types of
omics data right
so when you go through these courses and
each of these start with very basic
courses like introductory courses
introduction to bioinformatics
introduction to genomics so we start
with these introductory courses
and and then
it goes on to build up your
understanding
which is specifically the logic behind
this different kinds of data analysis
processes and also
of course there are different projects
which will have more focus on precision
medicine so we already have these
projects
for review modeling cancer precision
medicine or the patient-derived
xenograft model so there are
a numerous projects which are there on
precision medicine
as well as on cancer in general so we'll
first start
learning the logic with these courses
and see the different applications
and then we'll try to apply the logic
that we learn
to this different courses during the
entire
two month period so i hope ishaan that
was clear
for you
thank you antonio for sharing
yeah yeah the lessons are part of the
precision oncology workshop so let me
actually get
all of you up to date uh
with how this program is going to work
so i'll start with the registration
process i think
that will make it clear for everyone so
this
is the precision oncology registration
site i'm sorry if i'm missing out on a
few questions i will be sure to follow
up on all of the questions and coming to
you
in a short while antonio so this is the
precision oncology
registration so you see that the program
is starting on the 15th
of march and here is how you can get
started if you have already applied for
the program
we also have a discount code which is
running on till
the 20th of february so if you are
interested you can also apply for
that discount code but you will receive
it via email so here are three options
for you to choose from
i'll explain what three of these options
are
the beginner option gives you access to
all of the courses
as well as the projects however it does
not give you access to one-on-one mentor
sessions
which the intermediate option gives you
access to where
beyond the live sessions you can also
request for
a one-on-one session with one of our
mentors who will be able to help you
out with any questions that you may have
during this
entire period while the advanced license
gives you access to 30 more days
so you go beyond the time period
of just the two months and get
additional 30 more days to work
on your own research project with our
team of research
fellows and our mentor team so this is
for someone who is
more interested in developing and
building their own research project
so this is why there are three different
membership
options so once you are registered for
the program
what is the next thing that you can do
so
the next thing that we do is first ask
you to update your profile so i'll take
olga's profile here for an
example so what is a complete profile
on the edut bio info platform you would
see that
we will always ask you to update your
profile and there is a two-fold reason
for this the first reason is that the
name that you see here
is reflected on these individual course
certificates so each of these courses
come with their own certificates
which is separate from the program
certificate which i
showed you so if you do not have your
full name
updated here and you have an edu profile
then the
certificate may only show the user name
and not your full profile
so you will have to update your full
profile and having a complete profile
also gives you the opportunity and as
well as others the opportunity to go
ahead and interrupt as well as
collaborate with you
we ask everyone to add your social media
links especially
uh for linkedin so that you may
be able to learn more about the people
who are there in the program along with
you
and in most of our programs there are a
variety of participants who are from
different backgrounds they may be
faculty they may be researchers
and they may also be students so it
gives you
a great learning experience and you
would also see the precision oncology
like the forum or the organization page
so let me also quickly talk about the
organization page
so once you are enrolled in this program
this is the page that you will have
access to
it has all the necessary details and the
resources that you need as part of this
training program so if you go down here
you would see the different
upcoming events where you see that it is
starting on 15th of march
so if you go you can see all the
different topics for the events
so this would be given as like the
syllabus that you would need
for the program then you have a forum so
what is a forum
a forum is a place so here is just an
example from a previous
uh precision oncology session where you
would find
all the necessary details from every day
the session like the day to day session
posted here
you can post your questions here and get
them answered so this would be a direct
medium
to ask any questions that you have
beyond the sessions
as well as post all of your queries here
we also post
about our top participants in the
program as well as share the session
recordings for
everybody in the group to see and then
you would see that you have access to
courses so everything is right here in
the tab
so the courses would also be added there
as well as the projects
so this is the resource that you get
on the edu portal besides this as we
already spoke about
in today's presentation you will also
have access to the server platform
so you cannot create an account on the
server to buy info platform so once
you're enrolled in one of our platforms
or have a license
we will be providing you the access to
this platform
so that you can run the different
pipelines that we
spoke about in this session today
so and the last platform that you will
have access to
is the code omixlogic platform or the
platform for learning
rn python as we already spoke about so
this platform again has a few free
resources that you can get started with
right away so i will be posting the link
again
in the chat box and now coming to the
question that
antonio has that uh if you can
apply for an internship opportunity yes
anybody
who has an interest in working on their
own research project can
apply for their for the internship
opportunity
so here is the link to apply that
i will type it out for you and post it
in the
chat box
and for today's session we do not have
we do not have any kind of certification
and also for anybody who is wanting to
start with their
own research project we first recommend
you to go through a
training most of our research fellows
who come and join one of the research
fellowship program have already gone
through the training
so that they are ready and they know
what are the different kinds of logic
and how to apply them to different types
of data sets
so once you are familiar with that
process it's much more easier to go
ahead and do your own project
or else the entire project process
becomes quite long
and you may not be able to figure out
how to go ahead with it
right at the beginning so we definitely
recommend
one of the training programs first and
then getting started with your research
project
and we also do not have a feedback form
for this session
but thank you so much uh for joining us
today and for sharing with us
all of your reviews and if you have any
more questions and i just
am seeing if i can if i missed out on
any other questions that we have
and also for anybody else who was
looking to apply
for the omics logic transcriptomics
program or the ngs data analysis program
this is the link to apply for that so if
you're interested in
ngs data analysis that is a program to
join
so okay so answering to biochemist if
someone is a beginner and has no
research experience we definitely
recommend one of the training programs
first
so you should if you are interested in
precision oncology or in cancer research
please sign up for this program because
this will give you an overview starting
from the
introduction and
going back and then going ahead
with the learning
and then once you are done with the
program like learning from the program
you can definitely go ahead and work
on your uh own research project like you
saw
semi or a lot of our other interns have
done
during this process
so thank you by chemist for sharing i'm
sorry i do not know your name
but if you please put down your email id
in the chat box we will be able to
get back to you
thank you so much ishaan okay thank you
thank you carson for
sharing and if anybody has any more
questions
please let us know
and meanwhile i would like to also
invite everyone
to go ahead and join
our groups that we have on linkedin
as well as on facebook so these groups
are open
for everyone
and we hope that you can join us on
these groups
so thank you again for joining us today
yes so i will be sharing the link with
everyone whoever has shared your email
ids with us
in the chat box and i hope that we can
uh
have you all in the upcoming program or
have you join us in any of the upcoming
programs so if you have any questions
then please let us know
you can continue to share
any questions that you have in the chat
box
and here are the links in the chat for
all the
social media groups that we have these
are free groups and open for everyone
so i welcome you all to join so thank
you so much everybody for joining
today's session
and for your review i hope to see you
all
in the upcoming days have a great
weekend everyone
yes say what is your question please let
us know
and we are about to end our session
yes we plan on having another webinar
soon enough
so we will be uh apprising you of the
date and time very soon via email so if
you have left your email id we will let
you know
about those upcoming workshops and
webinars that we have
so thank you again
you